[Music]
hello i'm hannah hart and welcome back
to edible history i gotta say it's nice
to see ya or rather it's iced to see ya
today we're getting the scoop on early
ice cream ice cream is actually one of
the older desserts out there despite the
fact that refrigeration is fairly modern
the history of ice cream is somewhat
cloudy with many cultures developing
many different types of frozen dairy
desserts but one of the earliest ice
creams comes from the middle east it's a
stretchy ice cream called booza booza
stands out to me because it's still made
the same way it always was
with giant bats
[Music]
not those bats these bats
lucky for us we're joined here today by
one of the few people who actually make
and sell it using the traditional
methods here to talk all about bouzou
with us we have maharana nicole owner of
la mirage pastry thank you so much for
joining us here today thank you for
having me too so what are the special
ingredients that make booz abuza number
one is sahala also we with the mystica
the secret to booze's stretchy
consistency is threefold salab is
starchy powder made from the ground
tubers of wild orchids mastic a piney
tree sap and finally beating the stuff
mercilessly with a big wooden stick this
pounding removes the ice crystals in air
from the cold concoction classically
buza is costa flavored which essentially
means candied cream what are some of the
original flavors that come with booza
the original flavor is milk sacha rose
water sugar
it often also has pistachios so we're
adding those too so are there any
special tools involved in making booza
yeah the special tools is
the spatula that's a scratch the ice
cream there the stick
will push the stick
this is
back and forth it's up a lot you have to
be very hot
wow flip it over we push it again this
is to make it more sticky that's like a
giant mallet can i see it
oh wow it's heavy it is
absolutely happy to
smash it yeah
so you're starting to make booze though
we need this yes okay um can i borrow
this yes okay great problem let's make
some booze
[Music]
our research didn't find a written
specific recipe for traditional booza so
we're going to go off my hair's
instructions
so these are all of our ingredients milk
sugar salad mustard salt rose water and
pistachios there's very little rose
water in here but
[Music]
you can smell that grandma coming a mile
away frankly i don't think this is gonna
be that hard
so let's get boiling baby
[Music]
first things first we're gonna mix
everything together then while stirring
we're gonna bring it to a boil and then
when it's boiling we're gonna keep
stirring until it's thick so we pour in
our milk
wow
oh i feel so opulent now we're gonna add
our dry ingredients
and oh
the rose water can't forget
never forget
and a little pour
and now we just whisk it all together
it smells good it smells good i can
smell the salab which kind of has like
almost a cinnamony nutmeggy vibe to it
and then i can also pick up the rose
water
i mean it already smells delicious
like i would drink this
yeah i would
fun fact about me i've actually made ice
cream before um
the process was very different
i used the ziploc bag
and look at the ice cream it's so good
you should never be ashamed of yourself
no judging
[Music]
so this is really starting to get thick
i can feel it thickening along the
bottom which is probably why we have to
constantly stir as it boils and it's
thickening a lot along the sides it's
almost almost like a really really
watery mashed potato that's probably the
cooking slob
the thickening
the thickening
sounds like a horror movie
[Music]
next straining
[Music]
nice i'm not gonna say it looks
appetizing now we take a break and let
it cool
[Music]
so let's talk about how we're gonna
freeze the ice cream obviously this took
place long before the days of
refrigeration so how did they do it well
they use snow we're not gonna use snow i
know bummer i asked i was like can we
get some snow
instead we're gonna use ice but it's
basically the same principle if you're
like where'd they get the ice it came
from the mountains
okay we got our ice
in between the layers of ice we're gonna
add rock salt
[Music]
now that we've got our first layers of
ice and salt we're going to make a gap
in the middle and add our bucket
i recommend if you're trying this at
home use gloves
[Music]
one last dash of ice
and now the final ingredient is time we
just wait for this thing to get super
cold
[Music]
looks pretty cold to me
i think we're ready to make our booze so
we got our booze nice and chilled and
now it's time to pour it in
all right booze let's do this
next step i think is spinning it to get
it to kind of wave up to the sides of
the bucket we're trying to use
centrifugal force
oh it worked
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah baby so a lot of our ice cream
has traveled up the sides of the bucket
so now i'm going to scrape it back down
in so the cold ice cream can go
mix in with the less cold ice cream and
etc so we just now it's time to scrape
oh that's ice cream it's working
now it is time to make boom i think i'm
a little too short
aha
[Music]
does it feel good i don't play sports
i've never played sports so i don't know
what my dominant hand is is it like
that is it oh that's probably this okay
ready
here we go
now that the booze of batter is frozen
we have to tie the bucket down so it
doesn't move around while i bash it here
we go
okay so we're halfway through beating
it's time to fold in our pistachios
[Music]
okay ah
got our pistachios
all right evenly distributed folded in
now we go back to beating
i gotta be real
i really hope this booster is worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
wait look it's getting sticky this is
getting sticky
[Music]
oh my god it works
[Music]
hey excuse me has someone been drinking
this room smells like
booze whoa
whoa
that does not melt right away it's not
really melting at all it's definitely
got
way too much rose water but i will say
that the texture's awesome it's so much
more dense it really stays in your mouth
longer to think that people were making
stuff like this 500 years ago long
before refrigeration so even something
as simple and sweet as ice cream has a
really fascinating edible history
oh we should say that every time
thank you so much for watching this
episode of edible history i don't know
how we're gonna beat buza but we'll see
what we make next time
[Music]
you